how's it going bros my name is peter pan
what's up by kea bird green how you
doing man today it's a beautiful day
today we're bringing back bang it I
don't know where he went
no no how did she escape I built her a
prison no come here
back to jail you can't keep getting away
with back back to prison yeah yeah yeah
you in jail
unlike Bengt you will never escape
what's up how you doing good boy
Jurgen damn you look tall today very
nice
that's perfect cuz we're gonna head out
with you I got r-tx working with NVIDIA
so we can actually finally see how the
world looks like with the damn shade and
oh my god it's getting bigger
that's right gamers nothing will stop
glorious VP tower PP towers so big I'm
30 years old
alright whatever I don't care I don't
care I don't care cuz we're getting back
banged I don't care it's too far and
it's food too dangerous to bring Sven
IKEA bird your two useless in general
you can't really do much we're
laboratory toss me that obviously need
to look after their prisoners so we're
just gonna head out you and me alright
let's have a quick snack and at the end
of the video we'll check out how the
r-tx channels look like I'm really
curious I've got a long way to go you're
against Merrigan we're bringing back big
goddamnit get some inspirational music
sigh oh do I feel inspirational right
now haha
Jotaro oh god she ever wonder what's
going on inside your own head
yeah I think it's next to the jungle so
we can check on the pandas and see if
they are are nice and toasty right now
that means is this way I just realized
god dammit
are you kidding me shut up don't ever
speak to your again dead
Jurgen smug and you are getting fat dude
you're so slow seriously oh I forgot I
have another idea guy let's put that on
hey being stupid pays off I keep telling
you guys smart and thoughtful overrated
hey guys we're back don't worry about me
you sir there who's there I knew you'd
think about what you done damn it I keep
forgetting I need this right no what do
I need
Oh smart this over a there that's
overrated who every Debbie doesn't
either
we're submitting parable heretics shut
up shut up yeah what do we get what do
we get what do we get eight armor a
toughness knock back resistance don't
push me bro god damn I look good god
damn I feel amazing
you're again oh they were ow look at P P
power glorious D P power it will reach
the skies and beyond one day March my
walk I forgot a bit things smart
overrated dad that if you're so smart
then why dad dish something to think
about gamers watch out for flaming lava
pit I know all the ins and out of this
man I know all their tricks and sleeves
that is not an expression well whatever
I don't care
oh we got our dinner oh that's a sad
well squeal I almost feel bad for it I
don't I really don't I don't
everything was die unless it's my friend
correct me up every day where am I
I'm telling you're getting too fat there
again we need to go more exhibitions
this is not gonna cut it
oh no scope jacket oh he's too strong
you can't nothing can hurt you
cheese says hey look the forest is fine
this is burning little bit
all right let's leave you here my man
I'll give you another ride armor at some
point okay now it's time for me to fly
to fly yeah Hey look the pundits are
doing great guys smash like of this
video how about that god damn you're
useless what do I do with pundits can i
oh my god what are you even stop that
stop it yeah YouTube freak now come on
come on
Oh where's the baby oh maybe maybe he
grew up and went to college let's just
call it let's just call it that he went
to college see they're fine let's not
hit the why I built oh yeah here's that
set another IKEA bird No bang
I traveled fjords and lands can I fly we
banked we're gonna try that I have a
feeling he's good at it
oh here we go here it is the land of
banked this is all my god we found him
right away guys what are the what did
the odds he loves me come back Bank I
love you I love you so much
I love you I love you come back all
right that can't be banked that's
impossible thinked would never leave me
that makes no sense he must have gotten
kidnapped my home was the safest place
on the earth why would he ever want to
leave it we'll have to investigate
there must be different forces working
beyond isn't that right I'm on to you
all right let me try can I fly with the
lava I feel like that's really dumb but
maybe you can
I repeat the lava cannot fly maybe
they'll love me if they eat some berries
boy you like bear uh-huh all right he
doesn't what
Bengt what are you going you can't he's
trying to find his way back home oh my
God look he loves me
look Bengt I have your nametag I found
it I found your nametag pink there you
go you're with me now come let's live
forever
oh god it's late we're gonna have to
sleep sleep just need to find a place
that is oh god they're already here
sleep sleep all right don't go anywhere
while I sleep sleep sleep all right that
was good oh my god I lost him are you
kidding me you losers are you serious
Bengt
oh yeah here the nametag thing I'm not
so bad I'm swear world are you kidding
me there's a freaking cat dude I want to
heal it so bad but I people get mad so
I'm not gonna do it bang gone ah oh
hello
have I seen this before I don't think we
got damnit why do I have that we're done
we're done with that
there's no treasure valuable enough as
Bing garbages this is garbages don't
even try this it's a trap set by the
Witch of the forest she's trying to lead
me away from pink Sun a man you see my
buddy bang why are you running homes
bro bro stop stop you got it you gotta
get that you're coming with me until I
find been each other new rules banked
was like a father to me you know well
you know the father were banked my god
the legends are true
stop you're not you're not gonna get
away with him you love me too much you
know it are you banked no goddamn Bank
took a banks nametag I bet that wasn't
even the real thing oh no it was a trap
that we chopped that woods I knew it
what the hell dude we were so close baby
to nint didn't stop swimming come here
oh Jesus try to get me killed
there's traps everywhere banked we have
to be on the baned bein to get it drop a
drop the leash I need the leash drop the
leash drop the leash drop the leash I'm
tellin you thank you thank you so much
you're dead you're dead I mean you're
coming with me
same thing at this way I'm joking I'm
joking we're fine look we love each
other right
what's your name Bayne faint get it ha
ha all right getting the bub
[Music]
enjoy your home for the last time faint
enjoy it so what's your hobbies man
goddamn eight more trends you play
volleyball
oh dude that's that big well play some
you don't know you're pretty good shut
up shut up ain't volleyball is a team
sport god damn it I wash it off animate
to know that oh god we're far away
there's the island upon this so pretty I
can't wait to see how it looks like with
our TX actually got it to manage to work
with my own world as well which is kind
of difficult not difficult but kind of
annoying and to set up I'm alright
getting the boat in the boat alright get
in the boat get in the boat get into
flippin debating about surely there's a
way to get them in the boat right yes oh
oh you comfortable cuz I'm oh boy your
momma bed
oh look your four is still burning hey
wait wait
say goodbye to your wife okay that's
enough yeah no one died we forgot about
no one and we brought two more people
hell yeah
yeah oh I forgot about your get never
mind okay I'm just gonna leave you here
you'll stay there good boy good Punda
I'll come and get you later don't be
there's no zombies zombies aren't real
oh come back you're stinky stinky
you can't run but you can't fly huh oh
my god stop it he's crazy can you stop
that can you stop that please this is
expensive this is a Gucci leash you
should be a cheap you should be ashamed
of yourself is what I'm saying
help help you can help you can help oh
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
it's bury it very in lovely no no I need
me
you know you mixing so goddamn difficult
bumping alright when you're arrested in
a dress I need a goddamn virgin god damn
it
oh look they became friends that's
adorable they're best friends
look at that thing it will be you and me
in one day setting our different Sosa
part don't wear bangs
ain't I protect No oh he wants to
freakin Bunney
ah alright and now we ride back home and
now we ride back home gamers yeah
epic gamer win oh my god bang disco
crazy this is like paradise for you
bain't faint I keep getting your name
bro yeah you love it there you dude you
can roam around like crazy I look he
loves it here he loves it so much
look how much he likes it over here
because he's not resisting at all he
wants to be here I brought you all the
way is he sick what he god he's already
sick I'm a failure as a parent hey guys
look
No stay here you're good oh yeah yeah
yeah come with me hey guys look who I
brought
yeah the whole party's back together
he's a little sick don't go close to him
faint there we go
watch this softball yeah ankles who
needs the memo right bain't
yeah we got bang and you get berries
come on come on yeah look he loves me
flies in the air that's how much he
loves me you get one you were good you
didn't escape
here you get to actually feel kind today
I changed my mind
you go you got nothing you get nothing I
change my mind alright let me just go
back and get bow to Panda
shut up both panda oh it's alright and
after we bring back baby both panda baby
bald panda that sounds good
I'll show off the r-tx finally I'm
really excited to see that where my baby
believe me me me me me me baby baby mo
panda baby bulb and get me no no the
baby boat panda alright one has to go
one has to go I'm sorry
I'm sorry but your friend has alright we
can get his husband we can get the wife
I mean it's cold luckily there's two of
them
I don't even uh crying you are crying
you're crying I aim for the zombie you
saw it I am NOT complicit I am NOT
complicit yeah nibble gain the boat get
where's your husband oh yeah just follow
me just follow me bruh you're fine yeah
we go now we go now shut up shut up I
see the side of your head that's
terrifying when you're far away and you
only have your I killed your husband I'm
so sorry it was an incident okay
we're cool that's awesome dang see I
know she would be fine with it
I know she doesn't care glorious P oh
you're not supposed to see this side of
people power come on we made it maybe
baby bopanna we made it yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes oh I hope
this is still working that'd be great
I know I built this thing to transport
back in the ancient days can i I'm
trying to hit the flip stop attacking me
you were like father to me you should
know that it doesn't work alright I'll
fix it I'll fix the next way maybe
what's the problem there's no pie
requiring this yes I chopped wood with a
diamond pickaxe you got a problem take
it up with someone else oh look at that
yeah we love each other we're gonna have
a good time over here
get in the boat get in the boat
get in the boat in the boat yeah hey
another fan we did it we did it god damn
it where's the arigon oh jesus oh god
it's a nightmare guys all right we'll
settle the rest because I've recorded
two line let's just jump into Minecraft
RTX its run it runs on bedrock edition
which is kind of annoying god I hope
this works so uses the beta version of
Minecraft Windows 10 bedrock edition and
then you have to convert your world into
bedrock and you have to copy over all
the textures and yadda yadda oh my god
it's working
alright sighs show up before and this is
after I don't know man it doesn't look
that good okay that looks pretty oh my
god Jurgen what happened to you what is
happening to you you'll get texty organ
3 ahead whoa the water looks cool though
damn that looks good
whoa whoa we'd even like Benson whoa
okay I like this this I like the rest is
maybe since it's daytime like all the
objects have a will shine to them
the lights looks amazing there I don't
know man it's kind of ugly isn't it like
the water looks good and and that kind
of stop there maybe I'll play around
with that a bit more oh look the old
water sheep temple is back what their
shape why would he show his face to me
what does she please please I just want
a moment of your time I know you're dead
but I think of you every single day
elaborate DeFreitas meet eyes locked
inside this is so sad I'm so sad I don't
know it's just a reflection of the past
really we must afford me none of this
alright guys thank you for watching
another episode of Minecraft you enjoyed
watching gently hit the like button
preciate it
we have merch which I'm not wearing
today but it exists
we got the Jojo P P and we got the floor
gangway if you're interested supports
the channel thank you subscribe if you
haven't for some reason and I'll see you
guys tomorrow
yep in a world where science knows no
boundaries travel to land where no tuber
has been and explore
foreseen landscapes they counter beings
that are extinct
Levi enactors ancestors who collapsed
ancient items rediscover your favorite
scientifically accurate dinos what will
you create